this is cloud news plate Chadd me or
Gladney is spelt c HL ADN i and I think
it's clad me well if I put a violin bow
down here i can get it to resonate with
frequencies but we haven't got a violin
bow so I'm going to tune it to 450 Hertz
where where this thing has a resonance
and you'll be able to hear it singing
away quite nicely to you and as I change
the resin I'll go through the resonance
there and you get this sound coming out
this the middle of the plate is being
shaken up and down it's held fixed there
but the plate is going to bow out and
there are going to be places which I
can't show you yet where it's going to
be stationary and other parts which will
be oscillating up and down like mad in
order to visualize it what we're going
to do is put some carborundum powder
which is a little material which is
about point three millimeters in
diameter and sprinkle it on the surface
so I just do that gently and you can see
that I'm spraying it all over the whole
surface and then we turn up the
amplitude of oscillation
into this lovely pattern well we got
lines where the grains of carborundum
have gone where the displacement of the
metal is zero so it's shaking up and
down but this place it doesn't move at
all this is called the nodal line this
is the place where nothing is displaced
no displacement means nodes and the said
in the middle you get another node and
then round the outside you get these
beautiful lines symmetric for this
rectangular shape showing you these
nodal lines that's the place where they
like to be thrown so that's being thrown
up and down and if they end up there
they're not going to be moved at all and
so that's the place where they end up
without wanting to move I can also run
this experiment again at a different
frequency I if I turn this up to about
690 Hertz this plate and you're getting
these curved lines coming out
[Music]
in this case you've got another pattern
like that with lines of the edge okay so
we with a particular pattern now I'm
going to throw a spanner in the works by
showing you what happens if I use very
fine powders this is much smaller
diameter this is like a podium powder
which is very very small and I'll
sprinkle a bit on oh that's probably too
much over the top and then we'll see
what happens
and having done that you couldn't see
there I've got more particles in the
middle I've still got this pattern on
the outside with a heavier gray particle
but inside you have a yellow pattern a
square pattern which is lying between
this line on the outside and the gray or
in the middle equidistance and this is
the area where the displacement of the
plate is the greatest in English this
plate is flapping up and down and where
the amplitude of the flapping motion up
and down is the greatest that's where
these particles end up and the reason
for that is due to the effect of this
flapping up and down motion on the air
scaling this up to them let's take this
as a large particle and it's jiggling
about on the surface and it finds itself
at the place where there is no jiggling
motion of the Sosa's up and down it just
stays there this represents a smaller
particle and I have a little bed of them
and as this is thrown up there's a
partial vacuum in the air underneath
this bed of particles and the air rushes
in from the sides to fill that vacuum
nature of bores a vacuum so you find
that there is a flow of air underneath
these particles which gather them all
together in the same space so if you the
big particles decided to sit it out on
the sidelines like those those people
who go around at dances and sit on the
sidelines whatever you call them it's
probably drinking their beer and they
stay there and don't get involved in the
activities whereas these women all jump
up and down and then underneath and
they're all sucked into one area only
that's happening here look at it they've
made little piles and as these piles
rise up air goes underneath them and
instead of spreading out the air drags
them back into a little pile this was an
effect discovered by Faraday in 1830
1831 yes 1831 180 odd years ago and this
is called Faraday piling let me read
from his paper the beautiful series of
forms are sued by sand filings or other
grains when lying upon vibrating plates
discovered and developed by Chladni a
striking as to recall to the minds of
those who have seen them by the
slightest reference they indicate the
quiescent parts of those plates and
visibly figure out what are called nodal
lines
you